let's move now to Wisconsin home to
controversial Republican Senator Ron
Johnson who is best known nationally at
least often for the doubt he is cast on
things like the coveted vaccine also the
2020 election results and now Ron
Johnson is hoping to keep his job keep
his seat in a contest there in Wisconsin
where race has also played a role it's
where we find Adriana Diaz in the city
of Appleton Wisconsin Adriana good
morning
good morning Wisconsin is the only state
that President Biden won where a
Republican senator is up for reelection
so Democrats could flip a senate seat
here but in true Wisconsin fashion the
polling shows it's going to be a photo
finish on Election Eve Democratic Senate
candidate Mandela Barnes Wisconsin's
lieutenant governor topped kitchen table
issues from supporters living room
despite slipping in the polls since late
summer he told us his supporters will
turn out to oppose Republican Senator
Ron Johnson's positions on abortion
Medicare and jobs meanwhile in another
Milwaukee suburb Johnson rode into a
cheering crowd he focused on the economy
and the need for Unity and blasted his
opponent for believing in institutional
racism early voting has already
surpassed 2018 numbers now a source with
the Barnes campaign tells us they're
feeling quote cautiously optimistic a
source for the GOP party here says
they're feeling quote really good guys
it could crack 50 degrees here that's
practically scorching by Wisconsin
standards my coat's open and that bodes
well for turnout Tony
yeah Adriana it always comes down to
turnout and weather is a big part of
turnout thank you very much